good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast happy October 3rd Jackie
and I are in theme I was something but
I've no relate so much in this holiday I
love Mean Girls it's not even as much as
the next person but like that meme is
getting a little basic right like I feel
like I've idolized Mean Girls as like a
film but also just like as like my life
since probably the third grade and it's
like now everyone cuz enews talks about
it like it's cool now like please I bet
I'm like over it it's always been cool
but it's like now that everyone's yeah
it just makes it less fun you know
Jackie just gave me it's being a pink
Jackie just gave me like three of them
you know she's inside an activity
gusting chewable tums and that's their
like bubblegum flavored cuz I'm really
not feeling good and I have to board a
plane to Buffalo ticket sale but girl
with no calm and I'm like I don't know
what I'm still feeling sick or if I'm
just feeling like disgusted from that
nasty-ass pink bubblegum flavored [ __ ]
well that's better to feel than to feel
sick your symptoms sounded like what I
used to get all the time which was like
anxiety stomach so it's like you know
have to go to the bathroom but like it
feels like the insides of your stomach
wall are like inflamed yes like I don't
feel like I have to go to the bathroom
at all and luckily for you I have a bag
that I used to wear years ago on me so I
had two little crushed up pepto-bismol
so at the bottom I was so happy like it
was only gonna snort it up I was like
that's how excited I was
I think you're gonna start to feel a lot
better soon that's the goal because we
have such a busy day I mean Kevin
masseter here which is they came
straight from the plane which is just
like so nice and such dedication so that
we can make this work with my you know
crates it to our schedule I'm really
excited I bet she's even more beautiful
in person both of them we have so many
good questions for them from you guys we
have so many personal questions and it's
gonna be so great I'm so excited to talk
to them this isn't like a long time
coming
yeah I moved my jury duty for this and I
could have been at the courthouse today
will you put your civil service on hold
America can wait Kevin and Astrid can't
vote vote lock wedding 2018 yeah black
went that says I read that can you hear
me Kevin lock much better yeah anyways
it's 1003 on October 3rd okay we're
surely thanks guys for being
accommodating to every October 3rd ooh
spooky
I always get freaked out when I see the
time is like 710 no I know 3 1003 1003
is October 10 3 I get free time when I
see 7 10 the time because that's my
birthday can your birthday do that 11:06
yeah yes it's coming up it's sneaking up
on you guys 33 days away Oh
34 you haven't spoken about it yet I
feel like you're like because anymore
far out I don't know where I'm at like I
don't know what my birthday by this I
don't even know what I like want to do I
don't even really know what I want other
than obviously like a Gucci bag and
diamond earrings I really don't know
what I want guys so you know what it is
it's like when you're also getting
married at some point it's like you feel
stupid having like so many celebrations
do you know any mean like I had my
birthday in July a bachelorette party in
June bridal shower and then wedding
September it was like four months where
I'm like all right this is stupid like I
don't even want to celebrate it anymore
right I'm already feeling that way about
my bachelorette party which is in two
weeks no it's like no it's gonna be so
fun but I just am NOT in like bride mode
at all but once you get there and put on
the shirt that says bride like you'll
really have to embrace I ordered a
little booty veil from Etsy last night
except then the creator was like what
color do you want the bride announcing
just me
yeah they all look fine to me so now I
have jobs now I'm Steve Jobs but that'll
be a nice reprieve yeah and I said to
her go hollows also the birthday vibe is
hard to call when like you don't drink
anymore so but when you're a grandma
what is the vibe granny vibes what do
grandma's doing different over time that
would be lovely
there'll be so money and I go to the
country club and go like golf
lovely mahjong better you can't eat
dinner five o'clock bed eight it is a
dream a dream anyways it's our last show
of the week together so we've got a
thread count we have some pretty good
stories for you guys oh I just wanted to
give a personal life update because I
know that I spoke yesterday about
applying to business school and people
might have thought I was kidding and I
didn't know what if I was kidding or not
but then coincidentally Sam FaceTime me
my friend who goes to Kellogg who got
into Wharton um the Kellogg was just
more her personality and she just
coincidence I was like oh I was talking
about you on the show today about
business school and I was like I think
I'm gonna apply like Harvard Business
School and like she was like honestly
like you could do it and she was getting
me so excited and I was asking her about
the GMAT cuz that's like the one thing
but like I want hurdle and I was like
what is the GMAT even about
she's like it's like the SATs it's
reading writing no but that's good I
don't take a test all about this I I
don't really write baby it's really just
they have to go to business school right
but it's just your your psych regular
people skills it's like a logic so I
came up with a plan and I ordered a GMAT
practice test and I'm gonna take a
practice test if I get below a 500 I'm
giving up if I get 500 or above I'm
going to pursue this dream okay give me
one - how did you go I gotta go it's a
big book and what was it uh it was like
20 something dollars calendar you don't
hop around yeah
but anyways I'm really excited I was
think about it last night I couldn't
sleep at all are you gonna do the
practice test like with no studying I'm
gonna read the beginning of the book
first just to see what it's about like
and what they recommend but yeah like no
formal studying I just want to see where
I'm at if this is even if it got a shine
in the realm of possibility right so I
think that's a really good plan okay I
told Zach when he came home I was like
I'm gonna apply to business school and
like he was so into it and you like when
I tell him like I'm moving to Cleveland
he's like okay so we're splitting up
like he usually doesn't go for these
wacky ideas but he was so supportive and
I just feel really strong in my result
did you think of like the money we spend
on rent New York what we could get in
Boston I know yeah that's all I was
telling Cena tossing honestly she was
being so unsupportive she stepped out
for a second so I can tell talk to about
this I was like I'm gonna go to Harvard
Business School I obviously they I get
in she was like but what about the show
like she was just being so logistical I
was like Harvard waits for no one
Jaggi she was being Miranda when Carrie
went to Paris with all the questions
right enough with the questions
wait by the way you made the best call
that I can something game teri hatcher
Jackie so last night was a Valentine's
Day episode where she shows up to the
restaurant literally wearing a dress up
to her [ __ ] and she's like so like
shocked when like she like on the waiter
it's like fixing the table like and then
she falls back and knocks over the
waiter and like I just wanted to kill
her she's making the show inseparable
she's insufferable she she has that like
Carrie Bradshaw vibe of it's like you
don't know where you are and who you are
and I mean you're supposed to be dumb
and we're supposed to find a cue but I
find it annoying like you're a grown
woman with a child are we all good
snitch the intern just came back
we're betting on Kevin I'll shed that's
alright it's okay we have more than
enough time um I'm glad that you feel
the same way the end it's like she's
your happiness
wait it's like the shows about her but
it's not this it's the Bree van de
Kamp's world and we're just living in it
it seems to me like a curse like
wouldn't you when the show is about you
like everybody hates you time that it's
airing everybody loves it Chucky is up
coming on the morning shows that shows
whatever Nate's us no because there's no
answer actually maybe everyone's falling
in love with snitch it's possible cutie
in a turtleneck
alright well without further ado here
are the Fast Five story is that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast okay
first afraid that everyone's talking
about Kanye made Kim part owner of easy
after she after she turned down 1
million dollars I saw that Kanye West
loves his wife Kim Kardashian so much he
made her part owner of his easy Empire
speaking with Ashley Graham on her new
podcast quote pretty big deal Kardashian
speaking with Ashley Graham on her
excuse to talk just so she can sell ads
totally it's like I hate when like
people who obviously don't have a
passion for podcasts just to make a
podcast so they can like talking about
for enough like minutes just a place
like some commercial I completely agree
however I will give her the benefit of
the conscious one because she served us
a premium interview
oh yeah and she's like she's a good
personality too yeah but we'll see like
you know ever anyone can start a podcast
can everyone finish I don't never run
top the charts can everyone deliver week
to week can everyone be the number one
morning show in certain states like
Massachusetts and New Jersey no thank
you
Kardashian shared the bizarre
circumstances that led her to go into
business with her husband a quote a
brand offered me a million dollars to do
a post on you know some of their
clothing the 37 year old reality TV
starlet began and they typically I don't
want to say what the brand is but they
typically knockoff easy
Kardashian contemplated saying yes
because of the big offer but she thought
to confer with her husband first
who let you think right I know I was
thinking fashion Nova or like something
like that oh you know I didn't think it
was a like it's a brand that was gonna
pay her a million dollars to post on
Instagram which is like her going rate
pretty much I figured his fashion of a
Kylie does fashion / - okay
yeah and they do rip off everything
right
in a good way like they make it
affordable for people they have really
cute stuff and they had a product
placement in night school so weird
they're in Lincoln Heights yeah there
was like a fashion of a bag like sitting
at home it was and they have a very
they've stores they're in songs yeah so
that's I figure it's the fashion over
something like that where they make like
she really would call maybe even like
pretty little thing yeah um he was like
no babe I really don't want you to do
that she added it's understandable but
that's a lot of money
Mother's Day comes the next week in
Kardashian gets a big surprise from her
hubby the mother of three said that
along with her flowers was a special
envelope quote I open the envelope and
it's a million dollar check and it was a
note saying thank you for always
supporting me and not posting and then
in the rest of the envelope it was a
contract to be an owner of Yeezy and my
percentage
honestly like sweet but genius business
idea about from Kanye like whatever
Kimmy's invested in like she's an
investor and Lumi like turns to gold you
know right so it's like he was doing a
nice thickness into intentions were in
the right place but little does he know
is that this is gonna change easy
forever in a positive way
no but if she hadn't gone on this
podcast we would never know that she was
a part owner also like Jeezy does just
fine on its own better than Lumi week by
the way better than what aw beauty Kim
has been on two podcasts now yes I
really think that we should we can find
like a contact for her like press people
and we can write an email and I feel
like there's no reason for her not to
come on our show let me tell you why
one it's not like we had like a nothing
shell like a lot of people watch the
show over a million Millennials preached
a week okay
second of all like we are so supportive
like we're not gonna hardball her with
questions about like North Korea you
know they're like this set totally goes
with like her aesthetic like the palm
trees and I just think like I can't
think of a reason why she wouldn't
unless it just doesn't like work
timeline or it's just like she wants to
be exclusive about the interviews that
she does raehwan just doesn't want to
like put herself out there um I think
it's deafening in the realm of
possibility not like immediately
nobody really know Beks the podcast
round and we have a fighting chance and
she respects people who support her like
she like remembers you know the north
the north west remembers right and like
I
if I were to get into Harvard Business
School she would respect us even more
and that's one of the another reason why
Muscat we had an MBA like honor on our
staff right I'm here for it that would
just be why I'm gonna find an email and
I'm gonna start crafting it just being
like here are stats like we're very
prestigious but like we love Kim and
like we just think this interview would
would be good for everyone and we come
to her right we don't even need to do it
here it could really be a patio
yeah like we'll film it on the side you
know of course we wouldn't you're crazy
yeah I'm great remotely anyways
Kanye is an amazing gift giver is all
I'm gonna tell you like so creative
uh-huh and it's like when he gave I'm
really gave her some bonds yes
stocks and bonds and two of those
companies reached two trillion this year
so like she's rolling in it the Kim
effect I'm telling you every time Kim
becomes involved in a business
ShoeDazzle right um no he's amazing I
kept giving and it's like you would
think a million dollars is you know you
would want it now versus you know a
piece of paper that says you're a part
owner and something I wonder what the
percentage she gave her was right like
1%
I just keep pulling out like like little
disintegrated parts of the pepto-bismol
from my teeth I understand like the
taste keeps coming down I understand the
plight but just think about all the go
to that it's doing you I feel better but
also the toes always just makes me feel
better like please start at like 10 29
we sit here like dead silent and like I
can literally kill someone just cuz I'm
like angry and tired then once once the
toe starts like it's really magical it's
a roller coaster of emotions it's a
Ramona coaster
Judas eg people got engaged on the watch
happens I Baptist yeah [ __ ] thirsty it
was thirsty
I saw and toasters and I was gonna
comment like who who are these people
and I realized said they're probably
audience members yeah um thirsty thirsty
for sure but like the guy was really
nervous and it was really sweet and he
had funny references he was like you're
the Kroy to my Kim the Giovanni's my Lou
and it was cute
that's cute and I guess it was the after
show so it's like it's a winter every
but now we were talking about the after
show people got in games I can't believe
that they still do the after show on
Bravo it's like that's what brought
that's what the watch repins live used
to be like the whole format was like a
15-minute web show and now that's what
it is and like I think good [ __ ] goes
down on it but could you imagine like
doing a 30-minute show this show in 30
minutes with commercials like you don't
get a minute to say anything
No that's what I love and hate about
watch strap and slide is like when
there's two guests on that I really love
like literally the best episode ever
with like John Mayer and a housewife
like a couple years ago when you swear
that dirty ass hat and it was like so
good and I was like thinking I'm like
this whole [ __ ] show is commercials
and the time that they do have like
andis rushing them through it really but
it's not long enough to be an hour it
should be like 45 minutes I don't or
it's 30 minutes with an after show right
or 30 minutes with no commercials
between that one girl but a girl can
dream
um thought something she is like the I
love them we have snitch and I got the
fake ones from Target for camp toast I
got this one I'm so obsessed with TSW
like I can't believe I've never shopped
at CSW before I know I love them and I
loved the fake ones that I got so I
would probably invest the extra $20 and
get a real yeah it's worth 60 and I had
a promo code but since she tried to use
the code and it was that over I don't
but I got the honey extension yeah I got
it to change my life some one of the
toasters told me about it it's like this
extension you download in your browser
and every time you check out they like
run six million promo codes to make sure
there isn't like a sale that you're
missing and usually they get you meet
like $20 off yeah or like two but yeah
sometimes it's like counts nothing and
they're like sorry you don't have
anything I'm like you're [ __ ] you you
know they should do the money that they
save you they should put in like a
separate bank account and then one day
you open it and you have all this money
oh my god that's such a good idea yeah
it's just like helpful money management
this is a harvard business mind want to
see another Hartman businessman I had
came up with the greatest idea cuz that
all like the plumber in my house I have
like so many men in my house it's my
bedroom and I needed like cash to tip
them and I didn't have say you've opened
a brothel of course I know I wanted to
tip them but I wasn't gonna leave and
like leave all these men in my apartment
alone so I had to like leave it in an
envelope downstairs later like it was so
stupid but there should be like an
on-demand cache service we're like it's
over for cash but it's tough because I
gotta you know the person's not gonna
steal right and also you're so funny
because been literally had that idea
like years ago no no he like went
through the whole same process like we
hang out and to need the cash Huber for
cash the show so I'm really glad you
guys are married yeah but it's a good
idea um there's just execution would be
nearly impossible like how would you
know that the person who is delivering
it it's not just gonna run away with us
right or like get Rob's just a bag full
of money I don't know it's yeah it's
stuff yeah I'm still gonna do or you
could have just like that know them like
we got again into eighth I know but like
paperless world I know but there's
certain people you can read mo and
there's certain people you can't like my
cute dog walker was like 25 like I think
Matt Mohan but like I mean 90 year old
plumber like I'm not gonna send him a
bed moat
no you should get your your $200 via
venema just kidding the the book is
closed huh
the book is closed I'm done look we
didn't officially say it but I'm like
the chapter is closed a year later we're
finally putting a joke to bed it's
really gonna be hard for us the sisters
have parsed but um I think we could do
it I think it's the right thing to do I
agree as a person I'm like over it maybe
that was like about everybody okay
except for that video of the saying it
it was so cute and like it's like all
this time he's been lying saying that he
lost his wallet but really he's flat
broke he's so cute oh my god he's sick
like he's getting better his doctor came
literally like the doctor that Theo has
dr. Lisa Lippmann she's like I send her
a problem like a picture and literally
she's there in ten seconds like I don't
know how I feel is better health care
than me like I was just like yes
straighten like I couldn't even had to
go to Duane Reade and get a quail for
myself but like Theo had like in-home
house care like with a concierge doctor
he deserves the best
he's so spoiled totally and it's just
walked in and she's like freaking cuz
Kevin we had to sit down and tell us
everything I'm freaking out I got them
coffee
they look literally exactly how they
look like nothing different okay and
she's a professional girl what are you
tonight
when I need them I shake the hand and
then at the end I gave a hug okay yeah
that's one way to do it
okay next story bling ring cart - for
arrested for a string of burglaries
target
targeting celebrity homes oh my god
again a crew of four suspected burglars
has been arrested in connection with a
string of celebrity break-ins and the
crooks had a list of more potential
targets including the homes of Viola
Davis LeBron James and Matt Damon cops
said I guess that's what happens when
you move to LA from Cleveland you start
to get rocked
yeah Tyrus Williams 19 and three others
were busted by the LAPD
after break-ins at the homes of Los
Angeles Rams wide receiver Robert Woods
singer Rihanna and baseball player yes a
Puig according to the LAPD we have
become aware of a series
residential burglaries targeting actors
producers musicians and professional
athletes living in the LA area LAPD
detectives believe the four may be
responsible for even more burglaries the
crew targeted celebrities based on
social media posts and touring or travel
schedules of the owners who approached
the residences when no one was home
Authority said honestly all I can think
about is Kyle Richards like our thief
Jackie I was just gonna say did they
ever find the people who did that is
this then can we get her custom Birkins
back well this slick this sucks because
and her mother's jewelry because they're
using social media and like the
information that celebrities are putting
out in the world like to hurt them and
then it's like that's why celebrities
retreat and like don't share it's like
that's why Taylor Swift like doesn't
ever post on Instagram it's because she
doesn't anyone to know where she isn't
like that sucks
right me that's like when Kim like goes
on vacation and then comes back and then
post and it's like I don't were
real-time poster it's like I don't like
that but it's the burger is that it done
to us I didn't spend so should be
searching that cuz like this is a very
high-profile show like you never know
who's watching
hey burglars except I'm home all the
time I'm home all the time and literally
if you rummage through my [ __ ] you
wouldn't find one thing of value no
totally like anything that's valuable is
either like on me or it doesn't exist
and it's like you come and steal some
things from me honestly you're doing me
a favor because I have a little bit of a
hoarding sin you know you're
decluttering for us right so you know
I'm going to be out of town yeah I have
six boxes in my living room and honestly
it's just like you know what it is it's
like stuff that Ben says is valuable but
like isn't like there's this baseball
signed by someone and it's just like I
was back to our way last night he was
like money throwing out money and like
you don't even like baseball you don't
even know who this is you just know
what's value but we had went to a
baseball game with like a brand and then
this whole branded suite and they were
giving out these signed baseballs by the
call this weekend key players and like
it was great and now they're just like
stuck in my house yeah that's a great if
the boxes mysteriously disappeared like
no one would notice her crack like Ben
okay take them take them to a place like
a consignment store where they sell [ __ ]
like that
like the place that OJ stole from and
that's why he's in jail but sports
memorabilia store in Vegas yeah take him
there anyways glad to see these burglars
brought to justice it's just like please
like there's only room for one Hollywood
burglar and it's Emma Watson I
completely and Alexis Neiers
and it's it's Alexis Neiers it's Sophia
Coppola like
just stop trying to reinvent like making
burglary like glamorous but that ear is
over
this is 118 can't burglarize anymore
right and so you're not gonna get a
movie so really what are you doing
totally been there done that I give you
it gives a thing of your life and if
it's not worth like a biopic you gotta
you gotta shift gears we're definitely
where the biopic I'm like lifetime 1000%
yeah maybe maybe yes I was gonna maybe
even hallmark oh my god hallmark season
is coming up I'm gonna totally it's
almost like Thanksgiving I'm so excited
because I'm really running out of things
to watch like I am caught up on
everything
well me and Desperate Housewives I'm set
for like a month cuz I watch things
slowly
I'm jealous except last night I
restarted 30 rock and I choked I'm
laughing so much that is a perfect show
to start at night because like before
bed you can squeeze in like three
episodes and it's only like 45 minutes
last night I was bedridden with cramps
oh so it was so hard for me to find
something that watch I wouldn't bother
me hmm um and 30 rock was just the
perfect solution and the rural juror oh
my god I've watched every watched it
twice now once with you and once with
Ben and it is truly the greatest show
know it's so funny I was just laughing
so hard at so many things
no Tracy really is like the like he's
exactly what we say about like certain
comedians like he himself before he even
says anything is so funny and like he's
just physically funny like his big body
in his face and the character he plays
is so funny and I think he's really I
know you love Jenna but like I'm much
more of a Tracy now I'm becoming much
more of a Tracy out too especially cuz
in the early days like Jenna is annoying
oh my god the worst yeah like while
she's still things like the girlie show
is about her right and that part's
annoying but like the thing about her
singing is like so if I think it's like
I relate to that so much where she just
like sings at all times and she really
does have a good voice for sure but in
the beginning she does that less and
then it starts to come out more ya know
she gets better for sure but Tracy
really is like the constant like
greatest actor and Jack Donaghy oh the
best I love him so much but watching it
again now like all at once it's like he
really you know is an insecure man yeah
you know yeah and you know the woman who
plays his mom like just odd
really yeah and she's like an icon and I
don't know how you feel about him but I
love Kenneth I was just gonna say like
give me a gun with one bullet and I'm in
the room with literally Hitler and
Kenneth and Kenneth dies I love him so
much him and his big [ __ ] neck look I
can't stand
he's so funny no he's Mason Ramsey grown
up 100% and you know what's interesting
is like the actor is like so rich
because he even though he doesn't really
work
he noises like every anime and he's in
every animated movie and now that he's
like a celebrity from that show he makes
so much money like he works so much but
like never like anything that you see
he's living the dream yeah interesting
no being and like a voice in an animated
movie is literally the dream well
speaking of the Baldwin family sort of
Justin Bieber and Haley Baldwin did get
married without a prenup Justin Bieber
and Haley Baldwin got married TMZ has
learned them for some reason they chose
to lie about it
Justin Haley actually tied the knot last
month in New York City the same day they
got their marriage license at the
courthouse
they had a preacher on hand Jeffrey
Wayne a member of the faculty at NIACC
College near the courthouse I mean when
your best about the preacher why do you
go there done with him carlins
are they done with Hillsong completely I
don't know but they're done with Karl
and Cindy said it's because he tried to
hook up with Haley Baldwin
or Selena Gomez I forget which one
Selena Gomez one of his girlfriends at
the time but I'm I'm still team Karl me
too I love him I love him the witness
was Josh mal a friend of Justin's who
attends church home in Los Angeles fact
is people mag did get it right so People
magazine reported it and everyone
freaked out and then Haley Baldwin like
tweeted which like I wouldn't have look
if people magazine it said it I probably
wouldn't have believed it
then Haley Baldwin saying it's I don't
know why everyone thinks I'm married I'm
not like I'm like oh okay good People
magazine is wrong again so it's just the
whole thing this story is only weird
because she confronted it and lied right
this further proves entities conspiracy
theory about them which is that like she
this is all a big scam by the Baldwin
family especially specifically Haley's
dad Steven just to get a piece of that
uh Bieber fortune 250mm yeah as we
reported Justin and Haley both reached
out to lawyers for a prenup but now the
plot thickens we're told they reach out
the very same day they got hitch but
there was no way to get a prenup drafted
and sign that quickly so Justin and
Haley got married without a prenup and
there's been no movement to have one
drafted now it's called a postnup saying
that same as a prenup but signed after
the marriage one source said justin is
so in love he doesn't see the need for
one he's so high on drugs he doesn't see
the need for one do you see that video
of him twitching on mass yes
I don't know that like twitching it's a
thing that you do I'm asking is whatever
is what the internet says that is the
thing so I believe it and
it was wild yeah did you also see the
video of him in salina like in like a
bad part of LA like hears about it
trying to score some heroin I didn't see
it
that's great video anyways this just
gues proves what nd saying and are they
gonna have like a real wedding now since
or are they still gonna pretend like
they're getting married you know in
Canada this whole thing like what
started out as we thought was like a
nice thing it's like turning into a very
tumultuous and negative situation and
I'm sad to watch it but I'm also
watching it like front row with popcorn
you know and it's weird because I Justin
obviously like looks not well [ __ ] but
Haley has never looked better
no because she's supplying all the drugs
to him so that he can literally just get
married without a prenup because he's so
high and she's thinking so straight
because her master plan is finally in
motion right but it's like what
willpower she has to like not do drugs
cuz she could easily do drugs with him
and they could just like she could still
got his money but like you know what
it's like just take a look at Justin
Bieber like that is like an anti-drug
PSA if I've ever seen one like he does
not look good that hair in that video
and that was stache like things like
that make me feel lies okay good I'm
never gonna be like into drugs because I
don't wanna look like that
okay I'm too vain to do drugs here's the
thing though like if all the blinds are
right and Haley like really is you know
taking him for a ride I just hope you
know she can have all these money like
and still be like good a good boy and
kind to him you know like you can have
your cake and eat it too so maybe just
like use this opportunity to really help
better him and you can still get your
125 mil Justin Bieber has been like a
lost cause like for so many years and I
feel like there are so many people in
his life like who don't care about him
what I mean
I don't know I like gave up on him so
long ago when he was like egging
people's home that's where he lost me
right and then it's like he did a Comedy
Central Roast and all of a sudden like
all is forgiven well that was about the
world no that was a brilliant PR move
agreed and when he was like on his
apology tour did that roast and then
came out with like the best music ever
he was really on this path to
righteousness and he was involved in the
church and you always think that like
when someone's getting back into
religion like it really is helping them
grow and he was on this path for a long
time with Skrillex like working in the
studio all night but then he fell again
so it in that like one-year period but
since his album like I was here for it
and I believed it oh I didn't believe it
I saw him on tour he was lip-syncing
like he was still like billion
prostitutes like I don't
think she was really on the straight and
narrow but like they were doing a good
job of propping him up yeah okay
disagree I guess anyways congrats on the
wedding guys yeah where you registered
where do where do people register where
are you registered yes they've got
everything so when I went to register I
had initially said I don't have large
Keurig machines that come in different
colors that's the only thing they don't
have are you sure positive
I asked the coffee expert on the floor
oh okay because I had originally set up
a registry at williams-sonoma Bed Bath &
Beyond and blew me know so I'd like all
three price points like low medium high
and I went to Bloomingdale's first and
they literally had everything from like
$5 things to $500 things so I canceled
the other two like someone necessary
know totally and I understand doing like
lower price points but to me anything
that you would get me from Bed Bath and
Beyond is not a gift like it's a chore
oh my god no like I look at us and it's
chores you're getting meat or supplies
right right yeah it's not a wedding at a
freer for your wedding about you bungees
right yeah no that's like so you could
do the dishes right no I want fine china
you're really channeling your inner Bree
van de Kamp totally yeah but any so
Bloomingdale's really has all about
except for I'll have to register at
CARICOM as well okay I'm ready for a
bigger Keurig I'm feeling mine up they
have the wayfarer registries as well
Wow which I didn't know about but I'd
love that I can tell him yeah okay next
story in an ongoing saga between the FDA
and Jul the e-cigarette mutiny the FDA
seized is more than a thousand pages of
documents in a surprise inspection of
e-cigarette maker Jul the FDA surprise
EC current manufacturer Jul at its San
Francisco headquarters and seized more
than a thousand pages of documents
related to the company's marketing
practices jewelle has been in the center
of FDA's attention this year as the
e-cigarette company becomes a phenomenon
among teens the Food and Drug
Administration's TUI's thousand of
thousands of pages of documents
innocence prized of e-cigarette maker
Jules
San Francisco headquarters last week the
agency said Tuesday what kind of
paperwork marketing paper's like to see
if there's they are intolerable by
targeting teens but it was surprised so
they didn't know to shred him right
you got a shred yeah I was like I think
I was in a business part of town the
other day like where as one is as one is
and where I will soon be and there was
like a shred in truck outside it's legit
they have like these companies maybe was
it should have been the dual
headquarters Marga when you were an
intern what was your responsibility for
your last intern why are you sweating a
lot oh no that was that was two
internships again internships ago oh my
god I broke the shredder what kind of
problem just came did you work for her I
don't know why I did I did look at the
file of course no take pics but no I
didn't take pics because there were
people surrounding me but redder what
does that movie is it life-sized but she
has to piece back together the shredded
thing with tape dude I'm talking yeah I
think it's like sighs but why would she
know I don't think his life-size but
obviously one of the twisters will
figure it out yeah thanks guys thanks
guys but you don't have to shred
anything on this internship cuz we're by
the book as hell right yeah all digital
so that's should we literally don't have
a piece of paper for you to shred right
right Marga what's you taking on Jules
with all your friends Joel cuz you're a
team Thomas I mean everyone around me
Jules none of my friends rule I'm proud
to say surround myself by good people
okay but a lot of people like in class
and in the library like have the jewel
and they'll like smoke it and then put
it back in their computer to charge it's
like oh that's where they lose me but
they're like doing it in school and in
the airport it's like doing at a party
fine like people do we order things that
party then smoke electric cigarettes but
like kids in the library or like in the
bathroom you know what where they lose
me is they're charging it in their
computer and then smoking their computer
totally like I understand that that's
how it works but I just don't want to
see it like that or when we're like
you're in the club and you're charging
it in this and you're smoking what's in
this like that you're external that wild
it's that's a rave in this reading oh is
it
what did she piece back together you see
[ __ ] hard but that's already been who
didn't get of course that's so Rayden
that's so it's so mysterious me she was
really a triple Talent oh so all those
shows have amazing theme songs we were
singing Kim Possible yesterday totally
what's the even Stevens one we went to
the moon do you see cardi B sing yeah we
see she's our age how would you feel if
your father was dating someone your own
age I thought it was yeah walking
through the front door Oh God oh my god
order Oh God you are free to go totally
that'll be me at Harvard totally um
anyways I just feel like the war on
jewel um I mean it's just a little
random yeah it's like everyone is so
jealous of their success no and it's
like okay the war on cigarettes like is
here it's being waged and it's and it's
working like all these true commercials
from o2 from MTV and this less teens are
smoking the smoking rate is down for
sure but like people want to do
something everyone has a base so like
people are turning to jewel but it's
like you can't have that either
it's like what you just want everyone to
smoke marijuana like it's like would you
rather your kid comes home with like a
crack pipe or jewel these are our
options right and it's not gonna be
nothing because I kids be able to need
to her bail so like if it's a jewel and
jewels are okay we don't know yet
because it's still so new but was like
the most rebellious thing you did as a
child um like as a team yeah I didn't
really drink until mine was like eating
cuz we used to live in like the
healthiest house that's so funny yeah
and that's why we all ended up so them
only like would leave the house because
we like vacuum season you know our way
through New York and that was my version
of rebelling it's like that was a worst
thing you could do was like eat candy
totally like before breakfast yeah
spoiling your supper all right let's do
another one I really want talked to
Kevin out said okay fifth and final
story it can be bored with like the
worst news ever yeah jewel no just like
the news these days it's like I can't I
know many make layoffs Julie or is it
really so terrible what's the
alternative you guys and justice for
jewel with the W I feel like her name is
being dragged through the mud totally a
llama bagel and a frisbee Apple's new
iOS 12.1 emojis are here they are just
like never good a rare spot of happy
news Apple is finally getting a llama
emoji and a raccoon bagel necessary
frisbee and mosquito emoji to the
company said will likely add semi new
emoji for iPhone and iPad users later
this month beta testers and developers
who update to iOS 12.1 will see the new
emoji starting Tuesday beyond the new
and cute blood-sucking animals iOS 12.1
users will now be able to send a bagel
salt luggage compass hiking boots
softball frizzy frisbee and
Asian inspired red gift envelope to
friends and family also I chose this
story because it's big news for me
finally redheads will be reintroduced to
the emoji keyboard
after years of discrimination that's
right today I'm like we're getting a
raccoon but we're not getting redheads
we're finally getting redheads
identically got it's taken soul I can't
believe that it's taken so on and then I
was thinking about it it's like what
they did to us by shutting us out a a
inclusion for everyone except redheads
right everyone it seemed intentional
right and if it were any other minority
group like we'd be up in arms but then
I'm thinking about the red had a
community in like who's our champion
you're all shy we don't really have one
right and then it's like me I'm the
champion okay and I let my people down
you did even though I did complain about
it outwardly very often um I never
really did anything about it is there
like a you know there's like the
n-double-a-cp is there like some group
for redheads no there's not and I'm
gonna start it like a non-profit and
it's like people still are mean to
redheads and like they have gingers have
no souls
you get offended by the word ginger I
don't because personally I associate it
with ginger spice this ice girl so it
doesn't offend me but I know that you're
trying to offend me but you can't okay
what about this fire crotch offensive
that's me yeah yeah it's like a word why
are you talking about people's vagina
state of a soul that they're right about
that scare nobody every redhead that I
know it was like pale and like shy so
like so it makes sense when they stepped
on yeah totally you got to do something
I know it's like we need one strong
redhead you honestly like you need
Marcia Cross you know what she's
fighting her own battle Oh cheer she's
so busy with no like and also it's like
Conan O'Brien where are you like okay
Mel they heads yeah redhead you
technically I guess are a little bigger
than the morning toast like why aren't
you jumping this cause for us what do I
run Weasley he's like I don't know maybe
Jenny Weasley we have a chance yeah Ron
seems a little unattainable and like
Madeleine Pech like if you could stop
making out with your boyfriend for a
second and think about some real issues
at hand
that'd be helpful it's it's really tough
when you find other redheads who aren't
in tune with what's necessary know and
exciting you see another redhead is it
like when you see like another Jewish
person you're like um maybe like before
but I feel like I used to
like earlier my life be very aware that
I'm a redhead but now I like forget you
know yeah I get that but I feel like
other people don't forget like it's so
much like a part of me to them you're
like a different kind of person no dude
I'm going extinct I'm actually a very
much a minority and I'm suffering
discrimination at the hands of the emoji
keyboard so unfair and it's like nobody
cares like even little tiny violins are
playing yeah but if I if it were any
other group saying it like be very sad
sucks for you
well speaking of very sad here's what's
not very sad ash turning Kevin back
together finally reunited broke up on TV
so many questions we got a ton of
questions for them on Instagram but we
are also watching live on the YouTube
feed so if you have a question for Kevin
or Astrid or Kevin and Astrid
feel free to leave it in the comments on
YouTube we're gonna take like a quick 2
minute break to bring them out here get
some extra chairs and you know starting
it out so we will see you in a minute
you
welcome back millenials to a show I'm no
longer apartment because I'm still far
from everyone but it's fine I'll just
take a nap over here don't worry about
me
please welcome Kevin Nash straight from
bachelor in paradise we're so excited
because like I feel like Jack especially
was really like you're champions like we
were we were really rooting for you and
we're so glad that it worked out the way
that it did even though it did take you
know some drama together
there was a small hiccup yet I knew in
my soul that you two were meant to be
together so I gonna be okay would you
care to explain yourself yeah sure
myself I think it was a familiar
situation I've been in before and I knew
the way I felt about her but it just did
with my back against the wall I kind of
took maybe not the best way out but I
think looking back now I still think
it's probably for the best of the way it
went down if I would have shown up at
home with an engagement ring I would
have freaked out right I think about all
but I sure match our nation's not
expecting an engagement either I can
just like be together yeah I mean I
think it was it was like I've never felt
this way about a woman so it's not like
I have doubts about her it's more just I
wanted to go home and I needed to get
home and once I got home and cleared my
head I realized how much I missed her
words the pool for one hour
everything they do Becca Martinez is
pregnant too like they know everything
and so when I saw that before I watched
paradise to them when you guys broke up
I was like okay they were together in
the toasters group so that gave me a lot
of hope and I'm so grateful for that
yeah there's one of those things I got
home and I had some regret and I had so
I was really sad I couldn't get in touch
with her right away to never number like
or did you get to search for it it was
like in my hidden things but then he
messaged Fibby too and so I went looking
for it oh it was so we
[Music]
dated someone you didn't have their
phone number but when we were talking
about that imperative something you
realize when we leave here we're gonna
have to exchange it over yeah card so
that's my explanation I just I needed to
see it in the real world a little bit
this time I think it's because I've been
there before I know a lot of people the
last day I was sitting around with
Jordan and Chris and these guys talking
about engagement rings and what they
want to do and I remember just thinking
I've been here just go home I think it
worked out the way it should so how has
the real world been for you guys where
are you living for national
relationships yeah totally it's great
right now cuz we've been together pretty
much since the finale right are you tied
to your from live in Tampa Tampa
no not really I hadn't moved there like
three years ago to be around my family
but I quit my job I actually moved all
my stuff into storage right before
paradise because my lease was up yeah
and I was just I was gonna potentially
maybe move to Dallas and then it just
kind of no I'm just living out of my
suitcase that's great that's so true
by the way so how did each of you like
end up in Paradise this season well to
go last year but then the shutdown
happened so I was in the hotel room as
the shutdown was happening and was stuck
in the hotel room for like seven days
going absolutely stir-crazy like to
order room service I did but I didn't
know if we were gonna start again so I'm
like trying to eat healthy and not
completely pig out cuz I didn't know if
I were gonna it was terrible don't they
when they finally told us there was a
shutdown service all of us just ordered
like he saw like crazy amount like
bottles and wine bottles of champagne
steak cuz we're like whatever it's over
but then we all went to Dallas we did a
girls trip after the shutdown I was kind
of seeing somebody so then when they
asked me to come back I was like I can't
I'm broke up and he called me back I'm
like I'm down hmm so for you you have
such an interesting like career in the
bachelor world cuz like you're like an
all-star I can keep winning if you want
Thatcher in Canada that's right sorry
right I say this is the only one that I
actually know totally but like I'm
saying competition wise
that's right yeah you've got winter
games and you also like one right and
then you also one paradise because you
went home with a stroke so it's like
what's the key to success how do you win
tell someone you tell some other thirst
monsters like you're tipsy drinks I kind
of just wound up on Bachelorette Canada
like on a whim but that was a legitimate
relationship that I was in love I just
met someone that I thought I could be
with didn't work out in the end which is
fine Ashley it was a little different
situation I'm sure if you talk to
anybody who went to the winter games and
we knew people weren't coming in and
people there was no it was just kind of
hisses - Cass let's see what you can do
with yeah and Ashley and I became
friends and then you just kind of roll
with it and that was all what the
competition
exactly and then yeah we just ended up
at the end like figure skating and it
was a lot a lot less of what I got in
paradise it was more of like a structure
of conversation and French a lot of
friendships - I spent more time I spend
more time with Dean that I did with
Ashley right so when Ashley came to
Paradise and got engaged was that like
weird for anyone or nobody like Karen I
was weird for everyone yeah okay not
just me it was uncomfortable nobody
everybody was like what is she doing
here what why are they here that's yeah
and they said like I heard after the
fact that they asked for me to be like
on a date that day or they I guess Jared
tried to get me out of the picture for
the day and all this stuff by like what
what what show are you right I'm not
going I showed up so it was awkward a
little bit that day but they gave us a
one-on-one date card that night so don't
that's far more in the past for me
interests are you gonna move to Toronto
full-time you think yes wait for the
winner - gotta be done just because
we're traveling a bunch over the next
couple months and then once I guess yeah
except for Yogi's for that some people
people anyway so when you guys were
going to paradise were there people that
liked you do you know of each other were
you an interesting question each other
did you watch Knicks season and I just
want to say like I didn't think I could
dislike Nick vile anymore but then like
you got no chine and Angela got no shine
on his season it just goes to show like
how bad it is touch totally totally so
we're so grateful that we got to see
them paradise so how do you is no
question there do you guys follow each
other on Instagram did you know each
other oh no I didn't watch Nick season
until the end I remember watching it at
the very end when it was just like four
five I like kind of watched it a little
bit more Christina but I like mood
fast-forward for everything else and
just I don't know and then Bibiana sent
me a screenshot of her Instagram the day
before I flew to Mexico and today I
think very much like you guys would cuz
her and I had followed other on
Instagram and would like message back
and forth but I'd never met her til
Mexico but she always would be like you
guys would be a good match you guys have
to talk to each other she saw yeah so we
got it I'm gonna read a bunch of
questions from Instagram but probably
the most requested question was your
guys's take on this Jenna
Jordan Jordans scenario and what your
perception of it all is well Jordans
come to tell a dramatic readings of her
Instagram oh the captions are out of
control thing out of control forensic
expert waiting for CSI like a microscope
you love Jenna's phone like what she was
when you were in Mexico with her or when
they were unravel do you like how to an
eye opening
he had like uh he would like him add me
I was super clue
I just thought yeah I didn't really
think anything of her but he would kind
of make comments here and there but I
think because I was friends with Benoit
and when he showed up the things that
she was saying to him and then going
back to Jordan I remember just thinking
she's she might have a different motive
but we weren't too shocked be shocked
like when it all came out I mean I just
don't understand why somebody would type
that up in a text message like sent
voice memo like or you asked yeah
we got a question for you about your
clothes in paradise
where did you shop shop gray suede oh
thing well so people wanted to know how
you maintain like a beautiful face while
crying like you didn't have a good
that's actually we got the question
multiple times is that familiar paradise
it's like the less makeup you wore the
better because he had wear too much it
wouldn't stay on your face and then was
wetting off and it was disgusting so I
just stuck to like tinted moisturizer
like I think Lancome was the brand and
then highlighter yeah nice option but
you guys feel about Colton and being
about your his season is filming right
now you guys are friends with him in
paradise
honey we're excited yeah we actually
we're wearing them over here yeah I mean
I talked to him at the Reunion and he
was pretty sure he was gonna be it and
then we met Jason and Blake in Toronto a
few weeks ago they said the three of
them didn't know until the day before
and I had a group chat going like they
were keeping everything transparent
between the three of them they were just
like this is what I think this is what I
think and then Colden got the call I
just think he's too good of a story he's
my friend like we're gonna go skiing
with him at the start of December but I
will tell you in paradise Colton was
kind of on an island like he didn't have
really had many friends and me and him
would go and he would mean him we go
boogie-boarding it's the only place we
can't put a microphone on you so me and
him would go and talk in the ocean and I
think he's ready for everything he just
he just got kind of put in that virgin
to you all that storyline yeah it's
ready to clean slate himself and just
happy do you think that the process will
like he'll find success in it
for sure I think you well think so but
this is a weird question from I'm just
gonna Jen that big a kiss
sure I should who's raised in Germany
I'm so curious how when you came to the
States how you see the difference
between dating in Germany and like us
culture how did you maintain like
composure like physically in Mexico when
it's so hot and like every rose ceremony
goes on for hours like everyone's shirts
are like soaked in sweat and like doing
your makeup outside with those fans what
nur I brought a fantasy so like I had
the scoop from the girls from the I
brought an extension cord I brought a
handheld fans I would like put on primer
fan fan it in ya then and I just wore
less and less makeup as time went on
yeah and he made me work out there so
then I and it's so hot you look I really
eat a lot so you're just gonna sneak
into air-conditioned room oh right did
the new like drinking policy exactly
right like the two drinks in our thing
seems like it's better yeah shrieks an
hour is like a plenty yeah yes like the
only thing is you don't have a clock or
anything to realize like oh yeah hours
almost over I should get another drink
but then the wells did Sarah Hyland
never come and visit him the last three
questions I think I was thinking also no
because I think she was filming
something every time yeah so she
couldn't come he tried to get her out
you yeah that would be so premium have
you guys met her and been with the two
of them no I hung out with him in
Nashville I guess in July was last time
I saw him but now she was before it
before he moved to LA I always know it
oh right being another boyfriend yeah is
there anyone um on the season that you
are not on good terms with or that you
don't speak to anymore I mean we don't
like nobody does so you know stuff is
very strange cuz like nobody talks
coming alright
that was so wild what he did on the
reunion but like not surprising I've
never seen anything like it it was the
kiss I stared at Colton and she stared
at baby and we just did
I think she's doing wow I think she's
doing better heartbroken this is a good
question and then I'm done because
everyone's questions on Instagram no
offense extinct what what do you think
was the worst edit you got like was
there a moment that you were like pissed
about how they made you look or how they
like cut up something you said um not
for me no I think no maybe yours from
the first yeah like I never blamed
productions I know I'm on a TV show and
that's their job but I will say on the
very first episode I did say I was
excited to marry jasmine who was my
ex-fiance I didn't say Ashley but they
didn't even clip it like it's not like
they did it on purpose to me it's like
they those were two legitimate sound
bites but there that is so trickery no
but he's sitting there I said all of the
things Oh botched and it was like
offensive to me that you don't think
that I can see that Jen's been wearing
this bathing suit for a week straight
now and it's like she brought a lot of
bathing suits you know so I know at work
Kendall's wearing this this same outfit
yeah every single day it's like I can't
think it was what's actually happening
but if they don't put it in that order
it doesn't make sense to the viewer then
it's like because there's so much
happening at the same time she's certain
episodes for certain yeah and they have
so like they're gonna do the Tia Colton
storyline finish that through then move
on to the next thing so that's kind of
why they have to otherwise it won't make
sense for the viewer right because all
of the scenes are happening at the same
like I remember I was journaling one day
and I looked over
and there were like six scenes being
filmed at the same time I'm like oh this
is insane so I like it's cut and no one
you're watching and you're paying
attention to it it comes off as sloppy
but if it were the other way around then
just wouldn't make any sense at all so
how long after the show what was a time
period between you leaving Mexico and
then you guys were you kindling like a
week two weeks well we talked the day we
left yeah he had DM me and I was like
I'm flying home today and great day I'll
talk to you but we we spent 23 hours a
day together and it's hard when you get
separated right away I just need to like
make sure she was okay it wasn't like it
wasn't like real rushing to anything
right yeah the day we got home and
there's more just checking in on each
other and then yeah didn't take long and
like I wanted to talk to him first
before I started talking to all of my
friends because like you know once you
start talking to people and then they
give their opinion and then you start
kind of second-guessing everything so I
just wanted to talk to him first about
everything that had happened the last
day on the beach before I got everybody
all this opinion in the net my spoiler
so fast
before we even have like before we even
talked there was already spoilers about
us on the night so crazy that is crazy
okay so where can everyone keep up with
you guys follow your relationship and
your saga around the world I'm gonna
start a YouTube channel too you are sexy
firefighter calendars always that's it
just a lot of we're going to travel a
lot and now I'm coaching a fitness
retreat called active escapes we just
got back from Bali and I'm gonna do a
few other one worked out so much in my
life
torture yeah it was great actually I
really loved it yeah you're gonna fight
first I thought I was dying exhaustion
one day I actually also one of my
favorite things about your guys's
storyline is that you said that you
loved him first and you were so shook
and they thought that was so cute were
you like expecting it at all
I wasn't expecting it we had a
conversation I think really early on and
I remember saying to her that
had somebody go out of their way to
Aqaba what to chaste women I've never
had someone come at me and I think she
just remembered that and then in the
moment it just felt good
oh really that's when I knew personally
to you guys when he broke up with you on
live television not cool by the way
um you tweeted something so funny that I
was like yes you were like I know
everyone feels that for you such as
follow me on Instagram so I can continue
make sugar bear hair add money and like
I just so appreciate your transparency
on the topic so we love that just wanted
to let you know so if everyone followed
on Twitter guys what I'm in New York
make sure your fault morning toast at
the morning toast we do live on Facebook
in YouTube every day the morning toast
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time right yeah
tomorrow we have had the McMahon
co-hosting because I'm gone him and me
in Buffalo I have a show at 7 o'clock
sorry it sold out you can't come but I
do have a show at 9:30 dad is like 5
tickets left so you should get them and
then Friday is what Olivia oh right get
all the scoop on Olivia's engagement so
we will see you there
you